this video is brought to you by surf
shark VPN what's up guys
michael here don't freak out but i want
to talk to you today about reality
dating shows and love now I know I know
they're fake trashy and probably bad for
your brain but what if we can learn
something in the midst of these and name
catfights over champagne bottles the
unbelievab ility absurdity and
straight-up tackiness of these shows has
led many a spoilsport grown up to
declare reality TV dating shows a
uniquely modern plague signaling the
complete collapse of society and
honestly we get it but maybe in this
producer fabricated reality there's
actually nothing particularly modern or
new going on what have we told you that
the very things we mock reality TV stars
for doing on their respective dating
shows stem from weird love standards
invented by dreamy-eyed writers in the
18th and 19th century and worse what if
we told you that you're probably just as
guilty of it as this very unpleasant man
welcome to this wisecrack petition on
reality TVs lies about love and spoilers
ahead for your own love life but before
I get into it I wanna give a shout out
to this week's sponsors surf shark VPN a
VPN is an invaluable tool to have
especially when you spend all your time
online right now I am using my credit
card all over the internet getting books
running movies and even purchasing
groceries for pickup it makes me nervous
to input my info on so many different
sites but with a VPN I know that I'm
safe while connected to a VPN all of my
information is encrypted so my passwords
and bank info are all protected from
cyberattacks Surf shark VPN lets me
connect to servers all over the world
and works on all my devices so I'm safe
even when I'm mobile shopping from the
couch surf shark goes above and beyond
the traditional VPN by offering
additional security for any online
habits for example blind search blocks
targeted sites from appearing in your
search results and clean web blocks ads
trackers and malware it's great if you
don't want any sites to collect your
data and make sure the best online
experience if you use the link in the
description right now you can get surf
sharp VPN for 85% off its normal price
plus three extra months for free go to
surf shark deal slash wisecrack or hit
the link in the description
protect yourself online and download
search shark VPN today and now a quick
caveat there are tons of reality dating
shows but for our purposes we're going
to focus on a few culturally significant
ones that seem to share a perspective on
love
specifically the bachelor slash
bachelorette love is blind and the
90-day fiance televisual universe now
look we know what you're thinking why
even bother analyzing the way love is
portrayed on reality TV when it's ever
more apparent that tons of people are at
least partially going on the shows in
the hopes of scoring some profitable
skincare sponsorship or at the very
least to boost their Instagram following
I have three hundred and ten thousand
followers right now it goes up usually
every single day indeed the inherent
lust for fame that we see on most
reality TV dating shows can't be denied
and those ulterior motives are a
phenomenon in and of themselves
however we and some scholars still think
it's worthwhile looking at the kinds of
romantic narratives that these actors
slash real people who we will henceforth
referred to as characters choose to
enact and that the producers choose to
well produce because even when it's fake
or inauthentic these characters are
still parroting ideas about love that
are upon closer examination other
curious strange and also quite
ubiquitous for those who are uninitiated
in the trash fire of reality love a
quick overview on the bachelor and
bachelorette one man or woman is a giant
pool of potential soulmates
eliminating contestants each week until
they found the person they're apparently
going to marry when love is blind a few
dozen singles date insert reel pods
without ever actually seen one another
and try to find love
so I'm get engaged and then try to see
if they can successfully make it down
the aisle on the various 90-day fiance
shows Americans struggle with their
overseas relationships and see where
their love can transcend continents visa
restrictions I'm sweating to death
worrying about this dis visa now and
lack of air conditioning I'm like hot
I'm sweaty
I'm starting to freak out a little bit
so what could these clearly trouble
twenty-something lusting after each
other possibly have to do with 18th and
19th century writers to explain will
need to leap through a very brief
history of love and Western civilization
as philosopher Simon May outlines at his
book love a history there have been four
major transformations in the way Western
civilization to find love the first
occurred in biblical times and concerned
the value of love basically in this era
love became the supreme virtue because
it specifically signified the bond
between a human and God divine love was
at the time all the rage the second
change began around the 4th century and
concerned the power of love in this
framing loving God can make you yourself
divine the third change began in the
11th century and was all about the
object of love I need the person being
loved once exclusively reserved for God
divine love can now be bestowed upon a
lowly human being especially if they
were hot that brings us to the fourth
day which occurred in the 18th century
spurred in part by the contributions of
philosopher and loverboy jean-jacques
Rousseau and later by other key figures
of the romanticism movement this change
was concerned with the lover who becomes
authentic through love
from this perspective romantically
loving another person is what's really
divine and what's more it's all but
essential to developing your true nature
ultimately as May puts it love comes to
fall and love with itself now probably
we assume slash hope that people loved
each other before the romantic writers
put foil to paper but at any rate there
wasn't the same intellectual framework
around love loving another person in
this era became divine
according to May this era of romantic
love is still alive and well today in
fact he argues that the notion of love
is a radical divine experience in which
you discover your true self and become
complete you complete has only become
more salient over time and for two
reasons first religion has become less
important leaving a vacuum in the
absence of divine love second our
society has become more individualistic
and less explicitly hierarchical we can
choose our own romantic partners for a
little extra context for most of history
marriage had more to do with property
transfer and political alliances than it
ever had to do with lusting over a
person who likes the same books issue
because we now have more freedom in the
development of our personhood loves
ability to help us achieve that makes it
seem evermore crucial and this isn't
without its problems we're not trying to
on your ideas of fairytale romance but
okay maybe we are as a result of
hundreds of years of philosophizing
about it love now labors under the
insane expectations that you should
essentially feel about a relationship
that way a devoutly religious person
feels about their god but hey no
pressure you don't have to take Mays
word for it either we all know that
society rhapsodize is the creme of
romantic love and use a person's
inability to find it as a pretty
objective failure I'm gonna die alone
but what did these smooch happy writers
like we're so think love to do for a
person according to May there were two
major motifs first that you can achieve
personal authenticity or the quest to
become yourself and dedicating yourself
to a loved one and in being loved
second the nobility of passion and even
sexual desire as a great source of
goodness and truth so TLDR hey love
makes you more authentically yourself
and be your passion is divine now to be
clear we've got no beef with romanticism
and its predecessors it was indeed a
profoundly important movement in
affirming the importance of
individuality of honest emotional
expression and a host of other generally
good occasionally sublime things the
problem is according to may our views on
love haven't evolved since we're so
gushed about is crushed and that's made
for a whole lot of achy breaky hearts
but what does this all have to do with
spending over a hundred thousand dollars
on a woman you met on a sketchy Ukranian
dating site a lot actually
in his book may outlines many myths
about love that have been propagated by
this whole romantic love is divine idea
and upon inspection we realized that
reality TV is a masterclass and dumb
ideas about love so let's go through a
few of May's myths myth number one love
is unconditional
it is neither aroused nor diminished by
the other's value or qualities it is a
spontaneous gift that seeks nothing for
the giver the notion of unconditional
love
according to May the most salient and
the most harmful of all love myths
propagated in our society and it is also
arguably the one most reinforced by many
dating shows unsurprisingly some of the
most herbal toxic people are really into
this idea on the show before the 90 days
about Americans finding love abroad
one couple constantly screams about each
other's manipulative behavior drinking
problems and alleged physical assault
she true shoes at my head and yet they
persisted at least for a while why try
to power through such unbecoming
occasionally dangerous behavior from
your partner well it's all in the name
of working things out and honoring your
true and pure love which by the way if
any of these things sound like your own
relationship
please don't or for another example
consider the guy who immediately breaks
off his seemingly normal relationship
with a woman he just met because in his
mind if she truly loved him she would
know immediately and unconditionally
that she wants to marry him after
knowing him for a few weeks people yeah
he always too quick similarly other
subjects who are almost definitely
getting scammed and/or catfished
basically excuse a long series of red
flags is just an obstacle in their
fairytale of unconditional love I know
it'll just raise more red flags with my
children it's easy for them to think bad
of Williams and think he's scamming me
but they don't know him like I know him
or take the bachelor in the Bachelorette
where the titular character starts out
dating over two dozen people all of whom
are asked to repress their jealousy and
their discomfort in the hopes of finding
true love with believe I'm not gonna do
what Ben did me last season I'm not
gonna fall in love with two girls
I'm gonna fall in love with you from the
get-go each contestant is agreeing to
emotionally untenable circumstances
filled with constant jealousy and
anxiety in exchange for maybe finding
love and yes we know being on TV but
things get even trickier near the end
when we have four characters all of whom
typically seem genuinely invested in the
lead taking them to their hometowns at
this point it is by now almost formulaic
ly required for each contestant to
verbally express their love to the point
where not doing so can literally get the
sent home what could be more
unconditional than telling someone you
love them in hopes of forging a
monogamous marital relationship while
they're dating three other people
this results in competitively lavished
declarations and promises of forever
looks like there's nothing I ever wanted
more just just look at you and like be
here wherever we are though you know we
could be in a little apartment trying to
argue about what the paint were put on
the walls you know like I just want to
be there then look that is sweet as hell
but as my new love consultant may would
put it love like everything human is
conditioned you probably wouldn't still
love your wife if she plays the trumpet
every day at sunrise or your boyfriend
if he murdered okay I have this crazy
thought that I know is crazy that maybe
Dwight killed my cat onto myth to love
transports us beyond the messy
imperfections of the everyday world into
a superior state of purity and
perfection this is most literally
propagated by the format of some of
these shows where contestants are swept
away to sublime beaches surreal
modernist pods and various beautiful
locales all over the globe this of
course reinforces our notion of love as
a fantasy best enacted in fantasy
locations then there's the insane
requirements demanded of contestants you
need to drop everything in pursuit of
love oftentimes giving up your job in
the process I've given up everything to
be here or if you're a man from San
Diego looking for love in the
Philippines
you might just liquidate your only
retirement savings to make one big
romantic play but it's also embodied in
the way contestants are depicted upon
arrival they're often posited as missing
that special someone
ie a partner snoring next to them in bed
I wanted to show you that I do have a
heart on my finger okay and it's open
okay and I hope that you'll be the guy
to complete it crazier things have
happened
yes of course this hopeful lady's
introduction has darker implications
that she is literally incomplete not a
fully formed person without romantic
love in her life perhaps more troubling
me are aforementioned 90-day love
searcher Darcy expresses hopes that the
top
she's going to take it upon himself to
make me feel like a woman
this of course necessarily implies that
Darcy can't embrace a rebel in her own
womanhood without the express approval
and assistance of a particular type of
man and on to myth three that love is
our highest duty to ourselves promoting
this belief is almost mandatory for any
contestant on a reality TV dating show
as previously mentioned new characters
are often introduced primarily by their
lack or the flaw that has made them
until this point unable to find a mate
ideal in produce for one thing I haven't
produced yet is love this makes sense
purely from a story perspective
audiences care about characters with
defined goals that they pursue but here
it suggests that this lack of romantic
love overwhelms the good of personal
accomplishment supportive family and so
on
what's more the competitive nature of
some shows further reinforces the idea
that love is an aspiration a prize to be
won for oneself I came here to win this
no girls are getting in my way this
supports Mays notion that the divinity
of romantic love is inextricably tied up
with the rise of individualization and
self-determine ISM you are in charge of
your love life and it's failures are
your failings so you better win this
goddamned contest it also manifests in
contestants swearing that they don't
really fully exist without the object of
their love Emily this is happen
I have to do all this alone f towards
now and keeping with animes earlier
points in this era of love we focus so
much on the lover and what they want and
quote-unquote deserve as to render the
beloved almost an accessory you get the
sense that this woman could be crying
over pilot Pete or Colton or whoever the
help this helpless the point is what the
men and women have really invested in is
the idea of loving nowhere is this more
apparent than when a catfished victim on
before the 90 days talks about why he
for example flew thousands of miles on
several occasions for a girl that
straight-up ghosted him every time you
tried to go on a cruise with her and
that didn't happen because of her
medical reasons right for him he's
invested thousands of hours and dollars
into this relationship fittingly the
language of investment comes up a lot on
this particular show or when a woman who
was definitely getting catfished fondly
recalls countless hours of texting and
phone calls even after it becomes pretty
clear that her English boyfriend is
probably a Nigerian scammer someone who
hacked his account must have got ahold
of my address
you gave away your address I'm still in
love with him now even if all of the
clips we've looked at were constructed
by devilishly adept and manipulative
producers they still demonstrate
something important or socially endorsed
philosophies about loved taking to their
logical extreme but what's wrong with
hanging on to a few sweet myths about
romance
well according to may the problem is
this when we view love as all of these
magical things we set ourselves up for
disappointment and upon being
disappointed our love easily lurches to
the opposite extreme bitterly resent in
loved ones and who so much hope had been
invested and writing off love as brutal
or impossible and it's not just
renouncing love it's well this we could
keep going you the reason things get so
particularly dramatic and crazy is
because in this case rejection is very
very public and expectations I eat
lifelong love are very high okay but you
might still be wondering if it's a
reality constructed by a SWAT team of
editors who really cares
well when reality TV couples parent
cliche ideas about love for the millions
it very quickly stops being about them
and starts being about us why is that
blame it on something called effect or
what scholar Misha Kafka calls the zone
of potential emotions or primordial soup
of feelings that also serves as the cusp
that brings the individual person into
the collective psyche according to Kafka
TV is a remarkably important purveyor of
affect in today's society a conjoining
divider that connects us to those
outside our immediate purview when you a
Moute even a little as Tyler's heart is
broken or as darzee pursues love with
hopeless vigor the TV becomes a conduit
of social effect for you what's more
Kafka reduced the consequences of dating
shows for our effect is particularly
salient because as a work of reality TV
it is a constructed unmediated that is a
lot of work goes into making it feel
like a simulation of reality and even
though we know that this reality is
mediated
the effect of seeing real people dating
still both simulates as well as
stimulates what's more Kafka argues the
choices that these characters have to
make nearer the choices that we
ourselves are forced to make in the
dating world in imitating while
exaggerating the stakes of our own
romantic lives
Kafka says these shows bring to light
aspects of love practices that are
indeed conflictual and contradictory
that is how are we supposed to find
practical lasting love in a world that's
obsessed with both tinder swiping and
magical soulmates so are we all destined
to keep parody myths about love is there
any hope for us don't despair may has a
solution he proposes embracing a new
different definition of love that is
based on the feeling he calls want
illogical rootedness or to feel at home
in the world to root our life in the
here and now to give our existence
solidity and validity and he argues that
this is literally the only requirement
for lasting love if ontological
rootedness is your only expectation Mae
argues you'll be much better equipped to
pick a partner who you can actually
sustain a relationship with and you'll
be able to do so with significantly less
pain as compared to the fairy tale and
butterfly's framework laundered through
media like sina prince it's like a fairy
tale in other words as Mae puts it find
someone who makes you feel groundedness
rootedness at homeless I know I know
easier said than done
but what do you guys think do reality
shows perpetuate harmful myths about
love that make us all crazy or are we
overthinking ourselves to death and semi
quarantine again let us know what you
think in the comments
big thanks to our amazing patrons hit
that subscribe button and as always
thanks for watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]